the first pale rays of morning spilled
across the back lawn creeping up over
the porch like a rising tide and pouring
twin rectangles of misty illumination
over the hardwood floors in the dining
room
Greg yawned and slid the glass doors
open wide feeling the nip of the late
autumn air on his bare feet
Louise lay naked on the deck outside her
chest rising and falling in peaceful
slumber she was curled like a kitten her
knees drawn up to her stomach her serene
face resting unfolded hands every
silvery hair on her body seemed to
Sparkle with heartbreaking clarity Greg
looked down at her and smiled the phone
call came while Louise was out thank
Christ
Greg it's me of course it was her how
could he fail to recognize that dusky
voice syrupy with wisdom beyond its
years I told you never to call me here
I'm sorry I'm in trouble his legs simply
crumpled from beneath him at that phrase
and he collapsed into the chair the
plush brown one in this study he'd come
up here to work when the burr of the
phone had intruded upon his plans
trouble she said in this situation that
could only mean one thing how far along
he asked about six weeks have you told
anyone
no just the lady at the clinic knows he
let out his breath in one great
shuddering sigh the sky is falling
he thought and he put his hand to his
head and squeezed as if trying to
contain the fragments well don't tell
anyone
duh Greg she said the inflection so
typical of her age and in that moment
Greg was seized with an unbearable sense
of loathing both for himself and for her
she was attempting to be flip but he
could tell she was on the verge of
sobbing damn her
there was a long pause in which neither
of them said anything Greg's brain
seemed to have gone on strike stubbornly
refusing to cough up any words of
support or advice as if it had gone
blank on purpose punishing him for his
what carelessness weakness stupidity
finally he said
I'm not sure I can deal with this right
now Louise will be back soon maybe I can
think about it and call you back later
she sniffled but didn't answer right
away Greg knew she didn't want him to
call back later
she wanted him to make everything better
right now but he also knew that she
would never tell him this
he wondered where she was and she was at
home in her room perhaps sitting
cross-legged on her funky lavender
sheets hugging his stuffed animal to her
pert breasts under the watchful gaze of
the shiny two-dimensional rock stars
that radiated feigned attitude from the
walls Greg had never seen her room of
course but he could imagine what it
would look like a girl shouldn't be in a
room like that and be having the
conversation they were having it wasn't
right picturing it made him feel like
the world's biggest shitheel Wendy she
sniffed again I'm still here I'll call
you back all right
after I've thought about what we're
going to do he could hear her mucus
inflected breaths clogging the receiver
and the sound disgusted him okay she
said at last but it was tentative
reluctant call my cell though not my
home phone da when his attempt at humor
felt woefully flat there was only hurt
sniffily silence at the other end of the
line he cleared his throat anyway I'll
talk to you tonight yeah
I love you Greg me too kid he winced at
the words as soon as they were out of
his mouth he was going to say something
more maybe just goodbye or everything's
going to be alright don't worry babe but
she'd already hung up he dropped the
phone back into its cradle it was late
afternoon and for a few minutes he sat
in his chair watching the dust motes
hovering in the sunbeams from the high
windows thinking about how badly he was
[ __ ] he closed his eyes almost hoping
that when he opened them he would be
somewhere else be someone else someone
other than Greg Braddock the cut-up math
teacher at the high school the one all
the kids liked the one who'd started
banging one of the pretty sophomores and
ended up with a little bundle of a
bastard as his lovely parting gift
when he eventually did open his eyes the
light in the room had shifted and deep
into a pumpkin gold hue that he would
have admired if circumstances had been
different the muffled putter of a car
engine in the driveway alerted him to
Louise's return and he leaped to his
feet without thinking looking around
wildly for a second absurdly convinced
that Wendy's words had somehow tumbled
out of the phone and now lay scattered
like blood-stained murder weapons in
plain view of everyone nothing was out
of place naturally but nonetheless every
atom in the room seemed to scream a
guilty verdict directly into his
stricken face he squeezed his head again
tight get a grip
can't let Louise see me like this he
breezed in and out slower and slower
until he thought he'd regained a
semblance of calm his hands still shook
a little but that couldn't be helped
pulling himself up to full height he
made his way toward the stairs with
forced casualness he can already hear
his wife's key in the lock
Louise was sweeping into the kitchen her
arms laden with bulging bags just as he
reached the bottom of the stairs oh
there you are she said smiling up at him
with genuine affection in her round
yellowish eyes could you help me with
the rest of the stuff I called you from
outside but I guess you couldn't hear me
I was in my study I must have dozed off
she was staring at him intently now the
groceries momentarily forgotten are you
all right Greg his heart began to hammer
but he managed to keep his voice level
sure don't I look all right well sort of
you just seem kind of pale are you sick
no no probably just tired she didn't
sound suspicious at all that was the
thing she was simply loving sweet
concerned for his welfare
Greg thought that was somehow worse than
suspicion would have been but then again
what did she have to be suspicious of
she didn't know a thing I've been kind
of beat today
maybe I am coming down with something he
shut up then afraid he'd start over
explaining himself and end up babbling
out the whole rotten story
her expression softened poor baby she
crooned
and crossed the room in her live way
cupping his face and her long long
fingers
go upstairs and rest for a bit if you
want I'll fix us some dinner that's
alright I'll just sit down here with you
he said all of a sudden he didn't want
to be alone in the Twilight bedroom his
impossible problem thundering around
inside his head like Godzilla crushing
all other thoughts underfoot so he sat
at the table and watched her as she
prepared some complicated pasta dish
moving among the appliances with her
easy grace he found himself wondering
why he had ever cheated on Louise why
the sight of the barely 16 year old
Wendy with her honey blonde curls and
tiny pink v of a mouth had compelled him
to forget his wife forget his position
forget propriety forget the law for
Christ's sake thinking about it too much
made his head throb what in the hell was
he going to do pay for an abortion would
word get out that he'd pay for it Jesus
everyone might already know about him
and Wendy and we're just pretending they
didn't know giggling into their hands
when his back was turned
Wendy might have told one of her friends
or all of them he pinched the bridge of
his nose
way to go Braddock he chastised himself
you have royally [ __ ] up this time
Louise said a steaming plate before him
then set out cutlery glasses a bottle of
red wine a basket of hot bread she was
in her 40s but she was still a stunning
woman she sat opposite him and fluffed
out her napkin Greg started eating after
he'd swallowed a few mouthfuls feeling
queasy ER and more unworthy with every
bite he had almost decided to just tell
her everything right here and right now
and damn the consequences she was going
to find out sooner or later wasn't she
he opened his mouth to speak but Louise
chose that moment to say oh and don't
forget about tomorrow night his mouth
snapped shut he had forgotten about
tomorrow night as a matter of fact but
he didn't think anyone would have blamed
him he swallowed another fork full of
pasta was at that time already he
glanced over at the calendar yes it
certainly was I won't forget it he said
and as soon as he'd said it the light
seemed to go on in his mind
it was almost 10 o'clock and Louise had
gone into her studio to work Gregg
refilled his wineglass almost to the rim
and ascended the dark stairs to his
study he could hear the stereo playing
muted by the closed studio door but that
was all he sat at his desk and flicked
on the lamp drinking his wine at the
harsh circular glow the phone was inches
from his hand but for a long time he
couldn't bring himself to pick it up
Louise was singing along with the song
on the stereo now and her mournful wail
coming through the walls seemed to
rattle his bones she'd be working for a
few hours yet but she might come up the
stairs to the bathroom or to ask him
something he had to do it now if he was
going to do it he placed his hand on the
receiver then he took it off again [ __ ]
he finished off the rest of the wine
leaving the crimson coated glass on the
desk he flicked off the lamp I'm just
going out for some smokes he shouted
through the door of the studio as he
bounded down the stairs I won't be long
need anything while I'm out Louise
popped her header on the doorframe
there was a dab of gray paint across her
cheek nope but thanks for asking
she blew him a kiss and then disappeared
behind the door again it was cold out
and Greg cursed himself for not bringing
a jacket the motion light mounted on the
side of the house came on as he passed
it and he dug around in his pockets for
his keys once in the car with the heat
comfortably blowing he eased his
battered Volvo down the long driveway
and onto the deserted road closed in by
tall black trees and lit only by the
stars twinkling overhead he deliberately
drove past the nearest convenience store
with its garishly illuminated row of gas
pumps after another ten minutes he was
driving through the more developed part
of town strip malls and dispirited
businesses mostly closed up for the
night he finally pulled into a gas
station he was sure he'd never used
before bright and cheery and new
situated on the corner of a two-lane
highway and a well-maintained
residential street miles from his house
the phone booth who was out near the gas
pumps not on the sidewalk in front of
the store that was why he had stopped
he deposited his 35 cents into the slot
and dialed Wendy's cellphone number
hoping to Christ the girl had it on
vibrate instead of ring so that her
parents wouldn't be asking about who was
calling her at this time of night his
fingers were so damp that the receiver
threatened to slip from his hands
she answered on the second ring Greg
it's me so have you thought about our
little problem the dissonance between
the high teenage wobble of her voice and
the sardonic old nosov her words was
enough to make Greg's vision swim yeah
I've thought about it and and I need to
see you I can give you some money for
the procedure but she'll have to come to
me to get it and I can't go with you
when you have it done no one can know
about this Wendy I mean nobody so
problem solved hard and cold as an
iceberg she sounded ancient Greg combed
his hand through his hair
damn it Wendy I can't do this you know
you can't keep it is that what you were
hoping I'd say that we could run off to
South America and get married a silence
then I didn't know what you were going
to say but I know you have your career
to think about and your wife that's
right I do I will come to see you
tomorrow night we'll make a final
decision then Wendy it's already decided
you have to do this I'll get arrested
for [ __ ] sake you realize he was
almost shouting and he forced his voice
down to a whisper peering over his
shoulder there were two other cars
parked at the gas pumps besides his own
both of the cars owners were inside the
store he could see them at the counter
behind the massive glass windows what
time tomorrow night she asked he curled
his body inward pushing the phone hard
against his ear to keep the sound in to
make himself invisible 7:30 and don't
drive up to the house pull off the road
a little way up in the trees I don't
want any even seeing your car anywhere
near and how am I supposed to find my
way to your house in the dark I'll come
down to meet you just get out of the car
and start walking and Jesus Christ Wendy
don't tell anyone where you're going
think of some excuse to tell your
parents
I will she cut him off is that all
he almost dropped the phone again then
looked around guiltily someone had come
out of the store and was pumping gas
staring off into space yes I think it is
fine then there was a click and he was
left listening to dead air he replaced
the receiver wiping his sweat off it
with his shirttail he tried to arrange
his face into a neutral expression as he
crossed the parking lot and went into
the store picking up a couple of candy
bars without looking at what they were
asking the clerk for the cigarettes and
a voice that sounded a little too shaky
and high-pitched he paid for his things
and drove back home eating both candy
bars without remembering doing it the
house was dark when he got there Louise
was already in bed fast asleep after the
dinner dishes were washed and put away
Gregg opened the sliding glass doors in
the dining room and watched the blanket
of night being pulled over his little
corner of the world
he'd been nervous all day starting at
the slightest sound and Louise was
beginning to think he was losing it he'd
given her some feeble explanation
weaving a story about some troublesome
kid in one of his classes a big burly
junior who threatened to punch him
Louise looked worried but Greg told her
it wasn't anything to be concerned about
he was sure she bought it but she kept
giving him odd little looks with her
gold tinged eyes she came up behind him
as he stood staring out at the backyard
and he jumped a mile she shook her head
really Greg you should take a day off I
don't know what's the matter with you
today I'm fine you just startled me
I was wool gathering he turned and
smiled at her kissing the tip of her
nose to convince her of his normalcy
are you ready as ever she slid out of
her robe in stood before him her taut
body defined in muscle and bone smooth
skin hugging her long angular frame she
was nearly as tall as he was balancing
on the balls of her feet she glided out
through the glass doors and onto the
wooden deck then she stopped and glanced
over her shoulder at him see you in the
morning she said with her usual wink
I'll be here he said he slid the doors
closed behind her and locked them
reinforcing them by placing the scuffed
broom handle into the bottom runner
she was still standing on the deck out
in the darkness her back turned to him
she was breathing in the sense of the
night her whole frame working to absorb
them to make them her own he turned away
he had never liked to see her change
it seemed impolite to watch the clock in
the living room bombed seven o'clock and
when he looked back through the sliding
glass doors the deck was empty except
for the to sagging chairs that they like
to lounge in when summer came sipping
margaritas and teasing each other about
the angry red stripes the plastic slats
left across the backs of their thighs
summer seemed very far away now he
turned out all the lights in the house
then spent the next half hour pacing
back and forth across the hardwood
floors twisting his hands together what
was he going to tell Louise once it was
all over he hoped he wouldn't have to
tell her anything but what if well what
if the job wasn't finished Louise was
sharp she'd figure it out he paced and
twisted well if it came to that he could
think of something the girl had been
stalking him pestering him for months
schoolgirl crush happened all the time
he hadn't known she was out there in the
darkness near his house all alone how
was he supposed to know she was one of
his students nothing more a most
unfortunate accident but nobody's fault
the cover story made him feel a little
better but he still couldn't stop pacing
and what about the pregnancy just a
schoolmate she'd hung around with
perhaps they'd been experimenting he
could say that would they identify the
fetus as being his he didn't know this
caused a fresh bout of pacing and
worrying he was beginning to exhaust
himself
calm down Braddock he thought you're
thinking about this way too much
at the stroke of 7:30 he saw the motion
light outside click on illuminating the
frosted glass panes on the front door
and his heart rocketed up into his
throat he stopped pacing his every
muscle quivering what if Wendy had
driven up to the house after all but
then he heard a low howling a sound he
had heard on many nights a mournful wail
like the world's saddest song rolling
over the grass hills it was close by but
got more and more distant as each new
phrase was sung he was struck by the
sudden urge to go to the door and look
out but he knew he wouldn't be able to
see anything
the woods pressed around the house like
a velvet pillow black and suffocating
and then he heard the scream far off in
the woods he had half expected it yet
when it came he found himself clapping
his hands over his ears that was better
for a moment but then in the relative
silence that afforded he began to
imagine the noises that were blocked out
by distance or by his clutching fingers
the growling of the great beasts the
screams of the victim growing steadily
fainter the ripping the tearing of the
young nubile flesh from the brittle
bones
an eternity past his arms dropped to his
side's everything was silent now
whatever had gone on was over and
whatever the consequences were he'd have
to deal with them he stumbled into one
of the dining room chairs and buried his
face in his hands he wasn't sure how he
felt now that it was finished mostly he
was just very very tired Gregg sat there
until the clock in the living room
struck eight he marveled at what could
happen in the space of a half hour
then he stood resolute and crossed the
room heading for the stairs
everything would be much clearer when
morning came he was sure of that and
with a certainty came a small lifting of
his spirits a terrible weight loosening
is slightly in his chest when morning
came everything would be just as clear
as crystal he thought he'd have a hard
time falling asleep but as soon as he
had stretched himself fully clothed
across the bed
oblivion reached up to take him the
first pale rays of morning spilled
across the back lawn creeping up over
the porch like a rising tide and pouring
twin rectangles of misty illumination
over the hardwood floors in the dining
room
Gregg yawned and slid the glass doors
open wide feeling the nip of the late
autumn air on his bare feet
Louise lay naked on the deck outside her
chest rising and falling in peaceful
slumber she was curled like a kitten her
knees drawn up to her stomach her serene
face resting unfolded hands every
silvery hair on her body seemed to
Sparkle with heartbreaking clarity Gregg
looked down at her and smiled as he
stared admiring her long limbs and her
fiercely beautiful face he noticed a
glint near her mouth and he crouched to
get a better look carefully so as not to
wake her he freed a bit of gold chain
from between her lips then straightened
peering at the object in his palm it was
a necklace with a pendant bearing a red
stone a ruby birthstone he knew he
closed his hand around it feeling the
warmth his wife's lips had imparted to
the cold metal then he put it in his
pocket he'd get rid of it later smash it
with a hammer and flush the pieces down
the toilet for a moment he enjoyed the
scene laid out before him the sky's
streaked with pink the grass shimmering
with dew drops his wife's still form
completing the composition a sleeping
Madonna in the immediate foreground he
breathed in the clear morning air
feeling it fill him with fresh promise
then he turned leaving the door open for
Louise when she awoke and went to start
the coffee
[Music]
Twilight had come upon the slopes of the
vineyards and a gentle caressing breeze
drifted through the open casement to
stir into further disorder the papers
upon the desk where Etienne de Lacroix
was diligently applying himself he
raised his leonine head the hair of
which had in his later years turned to
gray and stared vacantly from beneath
bushy brows at the formation of a
wind-driven cloud as if he thought that
the passive elements of the heavens
could if they so desired aid him in some
momentous decision there was a light but
firm tap on the door which led to the
Hall of the Chateau dellacroix blinked
as his thoughts were dispersed and in
some haste gathered various documents
together and thrust them into the maw of
a large envelope before bidding the
knocker to enter pierre his eldest son
came quietly into the room the father
felt a touch of the pride he could never
quite subdue when pierre approached for
he had a great faith in his son's
probity as well as an admiration for the
straight carriage and clear eye he at
his own age could no longer achieve of
late he had been resting a great many
matters pertaining to the management of
the Chateau door ay and the business of
its vineyards which supported the estate
on the broad shoulders poised before him
but Etienne de Lacroix had been born in
a strict household and his habits
fashioned in a stern school and was the
lineal descendant of ancestors who had
planted their peasants feet reverently
but independently deep into the soil of
France so visible emotions were to him a
betrayal of weakness there was no trace
of the deep regard he felt for his son
evident when he addressed the younger
man
where are your brothers did I not ask
you to return with them they are here
father
I entered first to be certain that you
were ready to receive us bid them enter
Jacques and Francois came in to stand
with their elder brother and were
careful to remain a few inches behind
him he was the acknowledged spokesman
their greetings were spoken
simultaneously Jacques voice breaking
off on a high note which caused him
obvious embarrassment for he was an
adolescent together thought dellacroix
they represented three important steps
in his life three payments on account to
posterity he was glad his issue had all
been mails since the early death of his
wife he had neither cared for any other
woman nor taken interest in anything
feminine I have here my son some papers
of importance he announced addressing
Pierre as you observe I am placing them
here where you may easily obtain them in
the event of my absence suiting the
action to the word he removed the bulky
envelope to a drawer in the desk and
turned its key allowing the tiny piece
of metal to remain in its lock I am
growing older his fierce challenging
eyes swept the trio as if he dared a
possible contradiction and it is best
that you were aware of these accounts
which are relative to the business of
the Chateau no no Cora stole three
you're as young as ever papa
do you name me a liar my children listen
Pierre yes papa I have work for you this
night the elder sons forehead wrinkled
but the work is over our tasks are
completed the workers have been checked
the last card is in the shed this is a
special task one which requires the
utmost diligence of you all it is of the
wolf
the werewolf exclaimed Jacques crossing
himself the other brothers remain silent
but mingled expressions of wonder and
dislike passed across their features
ever since the coming of the wolf the
topic of its depredations had been an
unwelcome one in the household of the
Chateau d'Or a
mon Dieu Jacques exploded the head of
the house have you two been listening to
the old wives tales must you be such an
imbecile and I your father rubbish there
can be no werewolves has not the most
excellent father chromic floated such
stories ten thousand times it is a
common wolf a large one true but
nevertheless a common mongrel a beast
from the distant mountain of its
ferocity we are unfortunately well aware
so it must be dispatched with the utmost
alacrity but the workers say Papa that
there had been no wolves in the fields
for more than a hundred the ever verbose
workers the animal is patently a vagrant
a stray beast driven from the mountains
by the lash of its hunger and I at
tienda lacroix have pronounced that it
must die
the father passed a heavy hand across
his forehead for he was weary from his
unaccustomed labour over the accounts
his hands trembled slightly the result
of an old nervous disorder the fingers
were thick and blunt from the hardy toil
of earlier years the blue veins were
still corded from the strength which he
had once possessed it is well said
Pierre in his own level tones since the
wolf came upon and destroyed poor little
margarita story tearing her throat to
shreds and the officers who almost
cornered it were unable to slap it
because they could not shoot straight
and it persists in it slashed the
shoulder of old Gavroche who is so
feeble he cannot walk without two canes
interrupted Francois excitedly ravaging
our use concluded the single-minded
Pierre who was not to be sidetracked
once he had chosen his way whether in
speech or action the damage to our
flocks has been great Papa it is just
that we should take action since the
police have failed I have thought this
wolf strange too although I place no
faith in demons if it but seeks food why
must it slay so wantonly and feed so
little it is indeed like a great great
demon in appearance twice I have viewed
it leaping across the meadows in the
moonlight it's long gray legs hurling it
an unbelievable distance at every bound
and Marie Paulo door of the kitchens
found its tracks only yesterday at the
very gates of the chateau
I have been told reveal jock flinging
his hands about in adolescent
earnestness that the wolf is the beasts
soul of one who has been stricken by the
moon demons by day he is as other men
but by night though he has the qualities
of a saint he cannot help himself
perhaps he is one with whom we walk and
talk little guessing his dreadful
affliction silence
roar dellacroix one of his clenched
fists struck the desk a powerful blow
and the sons were immediately quieted
must I listen to the ranting and raving
a driveling of fools and imbeciles am I
not still the master of the Chateau door
a I will tend to the accursed matter as
I have always will I not I've always
seen to the welfare of the dwellers in
the shadow of the Chateau door eh
and with the help of the good God I
shall continue to do so until the last
drop of my blood has dried away from my
bones do you understand in a quieter
tone after the enforced silence he
continued I have given orders to both
the foreman and the mayor that this
night the night of the full moon by
which we may detect the Marauder all the
people of the vineyards and of the town
beyond must remain behind locked windows
and barred doors if they have obeyed my
orders and may the good god look after
those who have not they are even now
secure in the safety of their respective
homes let me discover but one demented
idiot peeking from behind his shutter
and I promise you he shall have cause to
remember his disobedience
Pierre nodded without speaking knowing
he was being instructed to punish a
possible but improbable offender now we
are for intelligent men I trust said
dellacroix pretending not to notice the
glow of pleasure which suffuse Jacques
features at being included in their
number we are the Delacroix's which is
sufficient and as leaders we must from
time to time grant certain concessions
to the inferior mentalities of the
unfortunate who dwell in ignorance so I
have this day promised the good Foreman
who petitioned me regarding the
activities of this wolf to perform
certain things they firmly believe the
gray wolf is a demon and inhuman
atrocity visited upon us by the evil one
and also according to their ancient but
childish witch lore that it may only be
destroyed by a silver weapon
dellacroix reached beneath his chair and
drew forth a small but apparently heavy
sack appending it on the surface of the
desk he scattered in every direction a
double dozen glittering cylindrical
objects bullets exclaims Jacques silver
bullets amended Pierre yes my son
bullets of silver which I molded myself
in the cellars and which I have shown to
the men with the promise that they will
be put to use expensive weapons
commented the thrifty Francois it is the
poor peasants belief if we slew this
wolf with mere LED or iron they would
still be frightened of their own shadows
and consequently worthless at their work
as they have been for the past month
here are the guns tonight you will go
forth my sons and slay this fabulous
werewolf and cast its carcass upon the
cartload of dry wood I have had piled by
the vineyard road and burn it until
there's nothing left but the ash for all
to see and now yes Papa assented Pierre
and Francois is one but the Bois Jacques
cried what so fine a skin I would like
it for the wall of my room those who
have seen the wolf say its pelt is like
silver shaded into gray Jacques Etienne
Delacroix's anger flooded his face with
a great surge of red and bulging veins
and Pierre and Francois were stricken
with awe at the sight of their father's
wrath if you do not burn this beast as I
say immediately after slaying it I will
forget you are my son and almost a man
I will his own temper choked him into
incoherency I crave your pardon father
beg jock humbled and alarmed I forgot
myself we will obey Papa as always said
Francois quickly and Pierre gravely
nodded the moon will soon be up said
dellacroix after a short silence the
room had grown dark while they talked
receiving a wordless signal from his
father Pierre struck a match and lit the
blackened lamp on the desk with the
startling transition as light leaped
forth to dispel the murky shadows of the
room
Pierre came near to exclaiming aloud at
the sight of the Haggard lines in his
father's face for the first time in his
life he realized that what his parent
had said earlier in the evening about
aging was not spoken jocularly
not the repeated jest dellacroix had
always allowed himself but the truth his
father was old you had better go said
Etienne dellacroix as his keen eyes
caught the fleeting expression on his
son's face his fingers drummed a muffled
tattoo upon the fine edge of his desk
the only sign of his nervous condition
that he could not entirely control the
mayor's opinion is that the wolf is
stronger when the moon is full but it is
mine that tonight it will be easier to
discover the three turned to the door
but as they reach the threshold
dellacroix beckoned to the eldest a
moment pierre i need to speak to you
alone
the young man closed the door on his
brothers backs and returned to the desk
his steady eyes directed at his father
dellacroix for the moment seemed to have
forgotten what he intended to say his
head was bowed on his chest and the long
locks of his ashen hair had fallen
forward over his brow suddenly he sat
erect as if it took an immense effort of
his will to perform the simple action
and again pierre was startled to
perceive the emotions which twisted his
father's features it was the first time
he had ever seen tenderness there or
beheld love in the eyes he had sometimes
in secret thought a little cruel have
you a pocket crucifix my son in my room
take it with you tonight and you will
stay close to shock will you not his
voice was hoarse with unaccustomed
anxiety he is young confident and
careless I would not wish to endanger
your good mother's last child pierre was
amazed it had been 15 years since he had
last heard his father mentioned his
mother you have been a good son Pierre
obey me now do not let the three of you
separate for I hear this beast is a
savage one and unafraid even of armed
men take care of yourself and see to
your brothers will you remain in the
Chateau for safety Papa you were not
armed I am armed by my faith in the good
god and the walls of chateau de rey when
you have lit the fire under the wolf's
body I will be there
he lowered the leonine head once more
and pierre not without another curious
look departed for a long while
dellacroix sat a mobile his elbows
resting on the padded arms of the chair
the palms of his hands pressing into his
cheeks then he abruptly rose and
approaching the open casement drew the
curtains wide outside the long rolling
slopes fell away toward a dim horizon
already blanketed by the Dragons of
night whose tiny flickering eyes were
winking into view one by one in the dark
void above hurrying cloudlets scurried
in little groups across the sky lamps
were being lit in the jumble of cottages
that were the abodes of Delacroix's
workmen but at the moment the sky was
illuminated better than the earth for
the gathering darkness seemed to cling
like an animate thing to the fields and
meadows and stretch
evany claws across the ribbon of the
roadway it was time for the moon to rise
dellacroix turned away from the casement
and with swift certain steps went to the
door opening it the hall was still there
from the direction of the dining room
there came a clatter of dishes as the
servants cleared the table quickly with
an unusual alacrity for a man of his
years he silently traversed the floor of
the huge hall and passed through its
outer portals a narrow gravel lane led
him along the side of the chateau until
he reached the building's extreme corner
where he abandoned it to strike off
across the closely clipped expanse of
grass in the direction of a small clump
of beech trees the night was warm and
peaceful with no threat of rain a
teasing zephyr tugged at the thick locks
on his uncovered head from somewhere
near his feet came the chirp of a
cricket in the grove it was darker until
he came to its centre wending through
and past the entangled thickets like one
who had travelled the same path many
times and found the small glade that
opened beneath the stars here that was
more light again but no breeze at all in
the center of the glade was an oblong
grassy mound and at one end of it a
white stone and on the stone the name of
his wife dellacroix stood for an instant
beside the grave with lowered head and
then he sank to his knees and began to
pray
in the east the sky began to brighten as
though some torch bearing giant true
near walking with great strides beyond
the edge of the earth the Stars
struggled feebly against the superior
illumination but their strength
diminished as a narrow band of
encroaching yellow fire appeared on the
rim of the world with its arrival the
low monotone of prayer was checked to
continue afterward with what seemed to
be some difficulty Delacroix's throat
was choked either with grief for the
unchangeable past or an indefinable
apprehension for the inevitable future
his breath came in struggling gasps and
tiny beads of perspiration formed on his
face and hands his prayers became
mumbled jerky utterances holding no
recognizable phrases of speech whispers
and then they ceased altogether a small
dark cloud danced across a far-off
mountaintop slid furtively over the
border of the land and for a minute
erased the yellow gleam from the horizon
then as if in terror shaken by its own
temerity it fled frantically into
oblivion and the great golden platter of
the full moon issued from behind the
darkness at it left to deluge the
landscape with a ceaseless shower of
elusive atoms tiny motes that danced the
pathways of space dellacroix gave a low
cry like a child in pain his agonized
eyes were fixed on the backs of his two
hands as he held them pressed against
the dew dampened grass his fingers had
begun to stiffen and curl at their tips
he could see the long coarse hair
sprouting from the pores of his flesh as
he had many times within the past month
since the night he had fallen asleep by
the grave of his wife and slept
throughout the night under the baleful
beams of the moon
he flung back his head whimpering
because of the terrible pressure he
could feel upon his skull and its shape
appeared to alter so that it seemed
curiously elongated his eyes were
bloodshot and as they sank into their
sockets his lips began to twitch over
the fangs in his mouth the three
brothers crouching nervously in the
shadows of the vineyards started
violently Jacques the younger almost
lost his grasp on the gun with the
silver bullets which his father had
given him from somewhere nearby there
had arisen a great volume of sound
swirling and twisting and climbing to
shatter itself into a hundred echoes
against the vault of the heavens rushing
and dipping and sinking into the cores
of all living hearts and the very souls
of men the hunting cry of the werewolf
other than the fact that it was New York
City
there wasn't anything particularly
unusual about the arrival it took place
between 10:00 p.m. and 2:00 a.m. just
like always and like always a fat
gibbous moon hung in the sky like a
golden Chinese Lantern emerging from
beneath a black velvet drape there was
also the familiar smell of the car clove
oil and sweat and leather and then not
unpleasant tang of cheap roadside
burgers and the driving industrial music
on the CD player not loud but just
audible enough to insinuate its
punishing beats into the brain
establishing a rhythm for thought
Lusine smiled a little as she gazed out
the car window watching the twinkling
lights of the city grow brighter from
across the dark water
she never been to New York before but
Mars had Lucene had always thought of it
as a place apart a place so magical that
it surely didn't really exist a
fairyland like oz or Narnia she
certainly never thought of it as a place
you could just drive to and Mars's dirty
red Viper but reality was putting lie to
that belief there was the city rushing
forward to meet them as if it would
devour them whole the club manager put
us up in an apartment less than a block
from the place
Mars was peering through the windshield
with her cold blue eyes getting a
cigarette from her pack and lighting it
without even glancing at what she was
doing in a moment the thick spicy smoke
filled the air we're staying with some
guy who works the bar I hope I have a
place to park
Lusine did not comment because she had
not been asked to the miles went by as
if in a dream shifting lights and
bridges giving way to tower and concrete
and noise the energy and heat coming off
the streets palpable even within the
fume filled bubble of the Viper
Lusine craned her neck eagerly trying to
take it all in she had been to big
cities before of course in fact it was
all one big city after another and had
been for years
but New York was different
simultaneously seducing and repelling a
dazzling debutante and a decaying horror
Lusine wanted to cram it all into her
mouth and swallow it it was a Tuesday
night and traffic was probably as light
as it ever got in lower Manhattan but
even so it took nearly an hour of
inching circling and swearing before
Mars finally turned the car under the
darkened block where the oubliette was
where the apartment was
Lucine looked out as Mars proud the
street like a shark trying to find an
empty space along the curb miraculously
she found one only a little way down
from the club on the opposite side of
the street she pressed her vinyl booted
foot onto the accelerator and the Viper
roared into the opening with less than
an inch to spare
Mars reached into the back for her bag
which was also black vinyl and then she
pointed a commanding finger at Lucene
even though of course Lucy knew better
than to move or get out of the car
without permission
Mars got out her leather skirt creaking
and then she walked around to the
passenger side of the car and opened the
door
reaching for the silver chain that had
pooled in Lu Singh's lap the chain
attached to the collar around her neck
Mars tugged it just hard enough to be a
little uncomfortable and Lucene unfolded
her live body from the passenger seat
keeping her gaze down turned even before
they reached the club entrance leucine
could feel the music pounding from the
very ground beneath her beats that
simultaneously punished and soothed Mars
tugged on her chain and leucine looked
up taking in the nondescript facade of
the establishment painted a chipping
blood red with old frosted glass inserts
the door was open and some random
pulsing lights could be seen from deep
within the building as they approached a
black clad figure emerge from the
shadows silver eyebrow spikes glinting
you're some of the performers for
Thursday mistress Mars and leucine is
Adam Severn here
yeah he's expecting you just take that
first left down the hall past the
bathrooms he should be in his office
thanks Lucy and followed dutifully at
the end of the chain as Mars clocked
down the hall in her high-heeled boots
the smell of the place was strange and
yet intimately familiar the secretive
earthy scent of many bodies close
together mixed with a lingering pall of
cigarettes that were no longer allowed
to be smoked
Adam Severn the club manager was indeed
in the office a whip thin man in his
late 20s with a head shaved clean and
black framed glasses sitting on the
bridge of his hawk beak nose he smiled
as they entered and asked if they'd had
a good trip Lucy and only half listened
as he talked to Mars about the show on
Thursday about the other acts performing
about turning up a few hours early for
an informal run-through she liked the
sound of his voice and was content to
listen to the melody of its rise and
fall as she stood at the end of her
silver
her hands folded d merely in front of
her at last business seemed to be
concluding and adam and mars shook hands
Lucy knew better than to offer hers and
even though Adam had only just met them
he knew better than to offer his to her
he rooted around in his pocket for a
moment coming up with a set of two keys
on a plain ring Roman told me to give
you these he said handing the keys to
Mars they're both the same for the
apartment door he said to just go ahead
and make yourselves at home because he
doesn't get off work here until three
bigger bedroom is his he says you guys
can share the smaller one his roommates
in Prague Adam smiled at this and Lucene
thought he had a nice smile sort of like
a Wolverine you know the address right
the building numbers 134 only about six
down from here front door should be
propped open if not hit the buzzer and
someone will open it he's on the fourth
floor apartment number 18
he smiled again and Lucene almost smiled
back
but then caught herself welcome to New
York he said Lucy and followed Mars back
out of the club and across to the curb
where the car was parked Mars loops the
silver chain around her wrist to have
her hands-free and then she opened the
trunk and pointed inside Terri the big
one yes mistress Lucene reached in and
maneuvered their big black suitcase free
it wasn't terribly heavy though it
contained most of their everyday clothes
and all of their performing outfits and
accessories after years on the road they
knew how to travel light Mars grabbed
the small overnight bag and slammed the
trunk giving Lucene an extra hard tug on
the leash for almost not moving her hand
away fast enough
the front door of the building was
propped open so Mars glided in pulling
Lucene behind her there was no elevator
and Lu Singh's arms were starting to
ache from carrying the awkward suitcase
up the stairs occasionally she
deliberately slacked her pace or muled
her discomfort just as she could earn a
swift rebuke from Mars in the form of a
savage chain tug her withering glare the
apartment once they had managed to shove
open the tight metal door and fumble
their way to the light switch was a
typical Manhattan closet with a postage
stamp living room a cramped toilet with
a shower stall a slip of a kitchen that
looked barely used and two minuscule
bedrooms with worn hardwood floors and
narrow barred windows overlooking a back
alley
Lusine liked it immediately it was cozy
and oddly welcoming and had a lingering
animal odor that appealed to her sharp
senses at Mars's command Lucene carried
the suitcase into the smaller bedroom
she dropped it on the floor a little too
loudly
then shuddered with pleasure when Mars
used the long silver chain to swipe her
across the back they were both very
tired and once Lucene had undressed and
curled up on the end of the bed
she watched adoringly as Mars unzipped
her boots and tossed them aside as she
slid out of her leather skirt and her
black tank top
normally leucine would undress her
mistress folding each article of
clothing just so placing the boots and
perfect alignment under Mars's eagle
gaze but tonight Mars was clearly too
exhausted for games and it ordered
leucine immediately to her usual
sleeping place at the foot of the
mattress Mars now wearing only a red bra
and matching underwear stood staring
down at leucine for a long moment she
was achingly beautiful in this pose of
studied disapproval her hair was ice
white and piled and disciplined curls
upon her head her pale flesh was alive
with sinuous curves of ink after making
sure that leucine had coward's
sufficiently at her implied wrath Mars
yawned then leaned down and unsnapped
the collar tossing it and the chain
aside with a metallic clink that done
she slipped beneath the covers making
sure to dig her toes painfully into loo
Singh's ribs leucine sighed with
happiness and was asleep minutes after
Mars extinguished the lamp sometime in
the night she half awoke to the sound of
a key jingling and a
our closing nearby but in the presence
of her mistress she felt no apprehension
and soon drifted off again morning
brought the smells of coffee and sugary
baked goods which in turn brought Lucene
out of her deep slumber
Mars was already up her shampooed hair
hanging like spun platinum down her
tattooed back as she dug through the
larger suitcase
Lusine did not make a sound she just
waited and after a moment Mars turned to
look at her as if she had sensed her
consciousness get up and come here Mars
said and Lucien obeyed untangling her
cramped limbs Mars snapped the collar
back on and tugged the chain then
studied Lu Singh's face and body very
closely Lucy knew that she was already
beginning to change this near to the
full moon the hair on her body was a
little coarser and thicker the angles of
her face were sharpening no one else was
likely to notice anything unusual but
Mars always noticed get dressed she
commanded when she was finished staring
look presentable you have to meet Roman
Lucy and unearth some clothes from the
suitcase just a regular black gypsy
skirt and a tight purple t-shirt with a
black rose printed on it she didn't have
to put on any of her performing outfits
not until tomorrow night once Mars had
dressed and pulled back her still damp
hair she led Lucene out into the living
room which contained no furniture except
a couch two small shelving units crammed
with books and a cheap desk with a
computer on it it was at this desk that
Roman sat staring at the computer screen
a chipped coffee mug beside him and a
pastry dripping a dark red jam clutched
in one hand he turned as he heard the
mentor Hey he said hey said Mars but
Lucene had stopped in her tracks and was
staring at Roman because she could see
from his eyes that he was like her
lupine and she could hardly believe it
she should have known from the thick
animal smell of the apartment but she'd
been so tired last night and pleasantly
overwhelmed by the mythical city
a painful tug at her collar brought her
up short and she glanced at Mars's
pretty scowl apologizing with her eyes
say hello to Roman Mars commanded hello
Roman Lucien's voice was soft and
lilting but she could hear the
underpinnings of a growl all the same it
always happened a couple of days before
the change she didn't know if Mars was
aware of Romans nature and of course she
could not tell her
Lusine had never even met another
creature like herself save for her
mother who had died some years before
Roman was looking at her with an open
stare that barely masked a sort of feral
intensity she wanted to return his look
but she was aware also of Mars's
imposing figure just inches away
radiating heat and so leucine dropped
her gaze when the strange moment had
passed Roman took a thoughtful bite from
his pastry not minding that bits of the
red filling were clotting around his
lips and jaw there's coffee in there if
you want some and I got some doughnuts
and stuff there in that white bag I'll
get it Mars said looking significantly
at leucine as she said it you stay here
leucine deflated a little Mars must have
seen what had passed between her and
Roman or else she wouldn't have denied
leucine the pleasure of getting the
coffee and pastries and serving them to
her mistress she could sense Roman was
looking at her and willing her to raise
her head but she didn't dare Mars
returned carrying one mug in one pastry
and she drank most of the coffee and ate
more than half the pastry then put the
rest on the floor for leucine to have
leucine crouched and fell to happy that
Mars is odd mood seemed to have passed
so quickly it was a long silence as
leucine finished her sparse breakfast
licking her fingers clean of jam and
sugar and then finally Roman coughed
uncomfortably and said what had you to
planned on doing today I mean the show
isn't until tomorrow and I don't have
anything in particular I need to do if
you wanted me to show you around that is
it might be nice to do a bit of
sightseeing Mars said glancing down at
leucine who was still sitting on the
floor she's never been to New York
have you seen no mistress so Roman took
them for a long walk around the crowded
streets of the city talking all the
while as Mars glided along beside him
listening to him with her cold eyes
staring forward and her red lips curled
into her trademark scowl a few times
Roman deliberately tried to include
leucine in the conversation but she
resisted happy to simply follow along at
the end of her chain peering around the
city in silence in the early afternoon
they rode the subway uptown and walks
languidly through the met Mars pausing
to examine the intricately worked swords
and the arms and armory wing Lusine
thought it was a wonderful place and
stared eagerly at each object they
encountered trying to burn its memory
into her brain Roman was still talking
he seemed to know a great deal about
almost everything and leucine couldn't
help wondering about him wondering where
he had come from but after a while his
voice became forced and his
surreptitious glances in lieu scenes
directions seemed to be turning
desperate leucine could see his eyes in
the reflection from the glass case
enclosing a medieval reliquary and they
glowed green like an animal's eyes like
her eyes when the light was just right
at dinner time the three of them stopped
at the cafe in the American wing for
coffee and scones Romans sitting across
the table from leucine and Mars Mars was
looking at them frankly with her own
very human eyes which in their way were
just as frightening as a wolf's I'll be
back in a minute I'm just off to the
ladies she said and she laid the end of
Lou scenes leash and a little silver
pile on the tabletop stay here she
commanded yes mistress
Lucy lowered her head the moment Mars
had rounded the corner Roman leaned
across the table and spoke as Lucy Anne
had known he would
hey I know your relationship is none of
my business and I don't want to mess
everything up between you two because
she seemed happy and everything but why
leucine is that even really your name
leucine couldn't bring herself to look
at him
even though Mars was not there it's my
name now he lowered his head to her
level trying to meet her gaze but she
avoided it he sighed
you're like me leucine you could be I
don't know free like our kind are
supposed to be how did you get mixed up
in this why do you let her treat you
like that at this Lucene did raised her
head and she could feel her eyes
flashing fire at him could feel the
growl building in her throat I love my
mistress and she loves me leucine she
looked down at the table again you don't
understand
you're right I guess I don't a hard
swift clack of heels signaled Mars's
return and for a second she stood over
the table
casting both their figures into her long
shadow before sitting down again and
sipping at her coffee a strange smile on
her beautiful face did you have a nice
talk while I was gone Roman didn't
answer he just shrugged and took a bite
out of his scone leucine dutifully said
yes mistress
Mars looked at her an endless tide of
emotion and meaning in one single glance
and then she reached out and strokes
Lucien's cheek first softly then
fiercely digging her fingernail into the
giving flesh at the junction of leucine
jaw and neck leucine closed her eyes
relishing the sensation after that Roman
hardly talked at all when the museum
closed they rode the subway back to the
apartment
none of them speaking Roman walked to
the corner and brought back Chinese food
for the three of them and after that he
turned on the computer and left the two
women to themselves leucine couldn't
help but feel a little bad for him
though there was some other emotion
tugging at her to curiosity Shirley and
perhaps even a little longing a desire
to experiment with a different life one
among her own kind one where she was not
forever on the end of a leash where her
monthly change was not witnessed by
crowds of fascinated on lookers but what
would life be like without Mars they're
always at her side she could hardly
fathom it didn't
want to imagine it Mars was like an
extension of her an appendage her
representative to the wider world
losing Mars would be like losing a limb
the women went to bed early
Lusine undressing Mars carefully
lovingly and then curling up at the end
of the mattress she slept well and woke
late already feeling the changes
starting in her body feeling her skin
thrumming with anticipation when she
looked at herself in the mirror in the
tiny bathroom she could see the
lengthening of her face the striking
definition of her muscles
she liked the look of herself this way
wild and hungry Roman was at his
computer again another half-eaten pastry
in his hand he barely turned when they
entered the living room are you going to
see the show tonight
Mars asked him her voice barring the
slightest hint of mockery I'm not
working tonight he said without turning
around but I'll probably check the show
out anyway he would be starting to
change now to Lucy and thought and she
wondered what he did when his own time
came if he ran the streets of Manhattan
tearing at the throats of the lost the
homeless the drug addicts crouching in
narrow alleyways the thought of such a
massacre both repelled her and appealed
to her how did he keep from being seen
from being caught it all seems so
precarious so romantic at Mars's command
Lucene had packed their Performing
clothes in a bag that she carried across
her shoulder they left the apartment and
Romans silent back and walked down the
block to the club where Adam Severn let
them in and allowed them to leave their
outfits in the back office some of the
other performers were there also milling
around and talking many of them clearly
old friends Mars knew a few of them from
performances in other parts of the
country and she talked to them as Lucene
stood contentedly at the end of her
chain later a group of them went to
lunch and leucine tagged along smiling
shyly at one other submissive who wore a
tight black leather bodysuit and
accompanied his tall severely redheaded
mistress at the end of his own thick
leash after lunch there was another
ramshackle rehearsal back at the
oubliette with Adam Severn presiding
good-naturedly assigning everyone their
spot in the lineup and making sure they
knew their places and had the music they
wanted queued up at the correct time the
show didn't have to be flawless as many
of the audience would only be half
watching as
engaged in various forms of play
themselves but it was important to have
some sense of continuity and
professionalism
just to keep spectators from getting
bored or Restless lucene did her part as
she always did miming her transformation
as it was obviously not yet occurring
and then she and Mars cleared the stage
for the next act night fell and from the
cramped space behind the stage Lucene
could hear and smell the crowds as they
entered the scent of their sweat and
blood making her heart gallop like a
hummingbirds she could feel the
physiology of her body twisting back to
ancient shapes a memory of her distant
mammalian ancestors and she closed her
eyes and breathe in and out deeply
enjoying the prickly sensation of each
hair on her body standing at attention
both she and Mars had changed into their
stage clothes and loo scenes coarsely
haired flesh was almost all on display
covered only by strips of red leather
across her breasts and hips that were
specially made to tear away when the
transformation began in earnest Mars
stood by silver chain in one hand
riding-crop in the other wearing a
skin-tight dress of shimmering black
vinyl whose hem revealed black stocking
garters against tattooed white thighs
they were performing first the rising
moon would wait for no one as she
followed Mars out onto the club small
stage really no more than a raised
platform
lucene could hear the pulsing of the
music and beneath that the low hum of
the crowd as it boiled and shifted and
turned its collective attention upon
them because of the lights shining down
from the ceiling Lucene couldn't see any
individual faces in the audience it was
just one many eyed mass and though she
could not see the sky see the fat white
moon as it hovered over the city Lucy
knew it was there
her body was telling her Mars led her by
her silver chain and as Lucene walked
she could feel her shoulders hunching
forward feel her fingers and toes
beginning to lengthen and consolidate
the noise from the crowd was already
starting to swell as the change took
place it was unlikely any of those
assembled had ever seen a true lupine
transformation before and they were
riveted by it and perhaps a little
apprehensive for Lucene could smell the
sudden perfume of adrenaline in the air
Lusine dropped to all fours snarling her
discomfort as her limbs stretched and
bent
her barely-there costume fell away
though now there was no titillating
human flesh to see for she was now
covered with a thick down of silvery fur
Mars was standing very near talking to
the audience in her commanding voice the
chain held loosely between her fingers
as if she might drop it at any moment
the tension in the crowd was palpable
now Lusine heard a stifled shriek as she
turned her massive head toward them
letting them see her glowing green eyes
lucina's my slave is a human Mars said
raising her chin and smiling a wide red
lip smile that suggested she held a
delicious secret but will she be so
accommodating as a beast on this cue
Mars dropped the silver chain to the
floor the audience gasped as they always
did and Lucene trained well even in this
form followed her own cue by lunging
toward the first row of the crowd baring
her slick white teeth and growling there
were screams now and she thought she
heard a slight commotion beneath the
music that might have been a few people
darting from the room after a few more
moments of this charade Lucene turned
her head toward her mistress fixing her
with a flat hateful stare Mars stared
her down defiantly the riding-crop
raised she spread her legs in a
gunslinger stance planting her feet in
their high-heeled boots
lucene she commanded and again on cue
leucine lunged at her snapping her jaws
closed a mere inch from Mars's saucily
exposed belly the audience was in near
frenzy now thinking something had gone
wrong wondering why someone didn't stop
it in her wolf form leucine basked in
the attention making a great show of
fierceness snarling up at her mistress
flicking lupine saliva all over her
beautiful tattooed flesh at last Mars
drew back and swiped the riding crop
across leucine snout and even though
leucine loved the feel of it she
pretended it had hurt her she pulled her
head back and howled the crowd was
getting into the act fully now terrified
to watch but terrified to look away and
this was the point that leucine loved
the most when she knew everyone in the
room was with them fascinated mesmerised
and then there was a blur in the
darkness coming from the space at the
back of the stage and suddenly Mars was
no longer standing there with her crop
mistress of the Wolves in her black
vinyl dress the screams in the audience
began again in earnest but there was no
panic perhaps they all just thought this
was another part of the show it wasn't
for there was another huge mass another
wolf charcoal black with a red red mouth
and he had knocked Mars onto her back
and was straddling her his jaw open
above her quivering throat Roman he had
come to the show after all Lucene
thought in her oddly disjointed lupine
manner the smell of him was powerful and
fearsome he had come to kill
Lusine crouched on her haunches watching
utter silence had befallen the crowd and
even the music seemed to have faded into
insignificance Romans dripping canines
were poised ever so softly on Mars's
neck he had only to close his jaws and
her blood would shower the onlookers
with scarlet arterial spray
Mars lay on her back looking small and
vulnerable beneath the Beast
she had dropped her riding crop but her
face was composed her cold eyes open and
staring into those of the wolf astride
her she knew he was going to kill her
but she was not afraid
Lusine waited she knew she could attack
now defend her mistress tear the
interloper limb from limb he was no
bigger than she was it would be an even
match but she also knew somewhere deep
in her animal consciousness that this
was a test of some kind a growl began
very low in her throat Romans jaws were
beginning to close and as the edges of
his sharp teeth broke the flawless skin
of Mars's neck the first trickles of
blood began to flow and then among the
crowd there was panic for now it was
clear that this was no longer part of
the act no longer the safe manifestation
of transgression they had all signed up
for the blood was impossibly red against
her flesh yet still she did not flinch
she waited
Lusine waited at last just when bromans
terrible jaws looked poised to tear the
life from Mars's bleeding throat Mars
opened her mouth her lips as red as the
blood when she spoke her voice was
ragged and barely audible yet its
commanding tone was unto men
and leucine understood it perfectly
leucine kill leucine could not say yes
mistress
but in her wolf like way she thought it
as she sprang forward onto Romans back
and buried her teeth into his jugular
you